so will this show be a gift or a curse
the first proper trailer has called for
the newest ex member lady TV show the
Fox we got to be putting out gifted now
I wasn't entirely sure what to expect to
disco yet I'm skeptical because I mean
I'm often skeptical of yo these things
being adapted to TV that were originally
sort of working as film franchises
though obviously in the case of xmin
they've got a lot of source material to
pull from obviously Legion was awesome I
fell behind and by the time I got caught
up this whole season was already over so
I didn't do absolutely bastard reviews
but I saw all region and Legion it just
amazing and people really need to watch
it but it's a completely different
creative team so while it does show me
that Fox is at least willing to put
really good creative talent behind these
shows because it is different talent
behind gifted then was behind region I'm
not going to assume that they're going
to be anywhere near the same level and
I'm still not assuming that even after
this trailer which honestly I liked for
the most part I think there are certain
things that you know hit kind of very
familiar notes that don't thrill me you
know I the the high school bullies being
that severe it always kind of bothers me
and I'm not I'm you know I can't speak
for anyone else's experience I'm not
going to say bullies like that have
never existed anywhere but that's just
that it just feels like that's a
Hollywood bully I certainly never
encountered anything like that in my own
personal experience but it even if it is
somebody - in reality it's overused but
then so there's stuff like that and the
whole idea of oh he worked with the
government and he finds out his
daughter's a mutant I mean that's pretty
that kind of angle is pretty tried and
true I think the reason this clicked
with me is a nice emphasis on the kids
on the teens because I think one thing
the x-men movies have kind of failed at
so far and maybe new mutants will turn
this around but certainly up to this
point is the fact that they kind of lost
the youth end of it
at least as a primary focus I think the
closest we got to feeling like we got it
properly was the stuff with Bobby Drake
Iceman in x2 and sort of using him being
mute as a coming-out metaphor and so I
mean that that work and we had moments
like that you know him and pyro and grow
but they that was always secondary and
even when they gave us teenage virgin or
you know passing 14 versions of these
characters in x-men apocalypse again it
was secondary because the focus was
still on the adult character so I feel
like that whole angle of x-men which has
always been a pretty big part of x-men's
appeal I certainly continue to appeal
and part of the reason the series is
being able to renew continuously over
time is through the introduction of this
youthful perspective and showing the
impact of this stuff on a on young you
know mutants and how that appeals to
young readers and I feel like it they
haven't properly mind that in the
interim franchise and they are hitting
that note really well in this trailer
and that sort of like oh good this is an
underserved aspect of the franchise and
that I think as really will lend itself
nicely to television I think x-men as oh
not necessarily the x-men team but x-men
as a world because in my mind x-men is
kind of separate from the rest of the
Marvel Universe because it's just a cast
of external a stuff alone is so friggin
expansive but you know that sort of
world of x-men really does lend itself
to episodic television and that kind of
storytelling again not maybe necessarily
the main team because it's cost
prohibitive with how expensive their
power sets are and how big their
adventures are but character the fit in
that world you could easily build a show
around them and that looks like what
they appear to have done here I also
like the little nods like they mentioned
the Brotherhood they mention the x-men
they also kind of lay out in the trailer
itself yeah we're probably not going to
be seeing them or if it's going to be
anything it's going to be little Easter
Egg things I haven't done a ton of
research on the show so I don't know if
any of the characters we see have
already been tipped to be certain
established characters I don't know if
they're just completely original mutant
characters I think they'd want to get
some know
characters in there maybe they're taking
sort of the the agents of shield
approach where they're giving us
characters that are characters that are
know from the comic book but they're
going to gradually reveal them to be
that over the time kind of like ages of
a shield did with quake and Deathlok it
seems to be a cast of mostly lesser
nokay the only face I recognized was amy
acker I'm always happy to see amy acker
I liked her quite a bit but even with
her there the emphasis really does seem
to be on the season I think that's a
really smart move I think the only thing
that makes me nervous about this is
approaches I worry that if this works
and if this comes off really well that
it might render a New Mutants movie
slightly redundant to me in comparison I
think and this is supposition on my part
but I've always suspected part of the
reason Warner Brothers is having a
really hard time nailing down a flash
movie and I keep burning through scripts
and burning through directors is because
the flash TV show has been doing for now
multiple years all the stuff that you
would do in a flash movie so it's like
well we already did that how are we now
going to distinguish this from that
other than just pump a ton more money
into the special effects and I worry
that if gifted hits correctly it might
do the same thing to New Mutants because
the initial appeal of New Mutants as a
film is that oh we're getting the
younger generation these younger fresher
characters and and again they're gonna
have to find a way or an angle to
differentiate to beyond just well we can
show more expensive show off you powers
in the movie because we can afford it
you're gonna have to do a little bit
more than that and I'm hoping that Fox
has more self awareness than Warner
Brothers and DC you have shown up to
this point and have an understanding of
of knowing that they need to
differentiate that I'm hoping they
already have some kind of plan on
exactly how that's going to work out so
that one of these things is not stepping
on the toes of the other because I would
like them to both succeed I am really
hoping to see the x-men as an overall
franchise bounce back because apocalypse
apocalypse was not good I think less of
it the more that I think about it and
that was supposed to be like an epic
sort of you know trilogy closer kind of
movie and it just
it was a wet fart but now you know with
Legion being so good with Logan being so
good with Deadpool being so much fun I'm
hoping that we are going to get a
revitalize and it very carefully
um maintain not in like a micromanaging
way but like okay this this franchise
will do this this franchise will do that
this TV property will do this as funds
and like get everything like neatly set
up because again the x-men world is big
enough to support a wide variety of
genres and a free buttload of characters
so I was this was a show that wasn't
really on my radar I mean I knew it was
coming but nothing about it made me go
oh yeah keep an eye out for that but I
see this channel Mike actually I kind of
it hits me a little bit that that piques
my interest I might have to check that
out so that's my thoughts on the first
trailer for gifted what are your
thoughts on it whatever they are drop
something down in the comments and let's
talk about it don't forget to like
subscribe check me out on Twitter at
council of geeks give a listen to the
council of geeks podcast and the punch
like a girl podcast both available on
iTunes and stitcher and until next time
this council is adjourned
[Applause]